رئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان هو من اعطى
الاوامر لشن هذه الضربات بعد ان اطلع على
معلومات نقلها اليه وزير الدفاع التركي
خلصي اكار خلال عوده اردوغان من قمه
العشرين على متن الطائره اعطى هذه
التعليمات ومن ثم بدات هذه الجرارات
الجويه ليله امس استهدفت عده مناطق في
الشمال السوري والعراقي ولكن اهم الاهداف
هي مناطق في محيط كوباني القريبه جدا من
الحدود التركيه وهي المدينه التي قال وزير
الداخليه التركي ان التعليمات
لتنفيذ اعتداء اسطنبول صدرت منها وبالتالي
هذا الامر يفسر هذه ضربات الجويه قد تكون
ردا على هذا الاعتداء الذي تتهم تركيا
وحدات الحمايه الكرديه وقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وحزب العمال الكردستاني
بالتورد في الغارات اكثر من 15 موقعا في
اني وقتل رفعت واا قاعده منغا الجويه
ومناطق في الشمال العراقيه الى الان وزاره
الدفاع نشرت بعض التغريدات
للضربات الجويه وقالت ان وقت الحساب قد
حان الرد على الاعتداءات الدنيئه التي
شنها الارهابيون ولكن بطبيعه الحال الامر
الى الان مقتصر على هذه الضربات الجويه
المستمره ولم اا تتحرك اي وحده تركيه لبدا
هجوم بري وبالتالي الى الان من غير الواضح
ما ان كانت هذه عمليه واسعه برا وجوا
امامنا ستختصر على هذه الضربات التي تقول
وزاره الدفاع انها استهدفت
ومخاذنا وماذا ذات للقوات الكرديه وان
الاهداف اهداف عسكريه وتجنب تركيا استهداف
البناء التحتيه او المناطق المدنيه بحسب
وزاره الدفاع التركيه الى الان
ذكرت بان تركيا استخدمت مثلا تسيطر عليه
روسيا لتنفيذ هذه الغارات هل من تفاصيل
اكثر حول هذه النقطه وربما هل من معلومات
عن اتصالات مع دمشق وبغداد
بالنسبه لهذه المعلومه نشرتها وسائل
الاعلام تركيا قالت ان الطائرات المقاتله
من طراز اف 16 استخدمت منطقه جويه تسيطر
عليها روسيا بعد سنوات طبعا من رفض روسيا
لاستخدام تركيا لهذا المجال الجوي ولكن
همم رسميا تركيا لم تعلن ما ان كانت قد
تحدثت الى بغداد او الى روسيا او دمشق حول
هذه ضربات الجويه ولكن كالعاده حسنيه هي
تقول انها لا تستاذن احدا عندما يتعلق
الامر بالامن القومي وعندما يتعلق الامر
بمكافحه الارهاب وهي بالعاده شلون عمليات
جويه مستمره في الشمال العراق وايضا في
بعض المناطق من الشمال السوري ولكن هذه
المره الاهداف كوباني وتل رفعت وربما في
همم مرحله مقبله همم منبج هذه الاهداف في
الاهداف الجديده التي تلمح تركيا منذ شهور
على لسان اردوغان وزير الدفاع الى انها
ساتشون عمليه بريه لتطهيرها من التواجد
المسلح الكردي بعد ان همم لم تلتزم واشنطن
ولا موسكو بالوعود التي ابرمتها لتركيا
بدفع هذه القوات الى عمق ابعد من 30 كلم
بعيدا عن الحدود التركيه